TODD KERPELMAN: Hello, I
do believe we are live.
How about that?
Sorry for the delay, it's
all Colt's fault.
So we are here today--
COLT MCANLIS: It's true.
It's completely true.
I'm sorry.
WOLFF DOBSON: It is,
in fact, true.
COLT MCANLIS: Sorry, internet.
WOLFF DOBSON: Didn't think we
would go there this early in
the broadcast.
COLT MCANLIS: No, it's
OK, call me out.
I will apologize for
the internet.
It will not be not be the first
time I've done that.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Look them in
the eyes, now apologize.
TODD KERPELMAN: We are sorry,
internet, for making you wait.
COLT MCANLIS: Sorry, 3.6 billion
people, my fault.
TODD KERPELMAN: So, this is
the Google Games Chat.
We need a better,
catchier name.
I had Google Games Gab, but I
don't think that's better.
WOLFF DOBSON: No, that
is not better.
TODD KERPELMAN: So we'll
work on that.
Hopefully by the next time we do
this we'll actually have a
decent title for you.
WOLFF DOBSON: The Google
Games Coffee Clatch,
something like that.
You're the only one with
coffee though.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah,
actually it's tea.
COLT MCANLIS: Google
Gameville?
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, so anyway,
let's start with the
introductions.
So hi, I'm Todd Kerpelman.
Hopefully there's a little label
underneath my face that
you can actually see that will
show you my name so you know
how to spell it.
Let's see, over here to my
right, your left probably,
this is Colt McAnlis.
COLT MCANLIS: Hello,
how are you doing?
And if you would like to
contribute to our Hotline Fund
Relief, call the number live
on your screen right here.
Operators are standing
by to take your call.
TODD KERPELMAN: Or ask a
question on the little
moderator link below.
WOLFF DOBSON: Right.
TODD KERPELMAN: Let's see, to
my immediate left, this is
Daniel Wolff Dobson.
He is our Hangouts guy.
I'm wearing the shirt
in [INAUDIBLE].
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, I don't
know why you're wearing my
product shirt, but that's OK.
TODD KERPELMAN: Well,
it's warm down here.
For those of you not in the
Bay Area, the difference
between San Francisco and
Mountain View in the summer is
about 25 degrees.
So every San Francisco resident
has to have a heavy
jacket or a sweater or something
that they put on at
the beginning of the day.
And then somewhere in the
commute down, you
have to take it off.
COLT MCANLIS: It's layers.
WOLFF DOBSON: But by the end
of the day, Todd is not
wearing anything.
TODD KERPELMAN: And
gradually--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It keeps
getting hotter.
COLT MCANLIS: Especially when
Todd's wearing nothing, that's
the hottest part.
TODD KERPELMAN: I was just going
to say, it's a very good
thing we didn't schedule this at
like 4:30-5:00 PM, because
then we'd have to have--
WOLFF DOBSON: It's a whole
different kind of hangout is
what you're saying.
COLT MCANLIS: Speedo hour.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yes, then we'd
have to have age restrictions
and all sorts of fun
stuff like this.
WOLFF DOBSON: Wow.
TODD KERPELMAN: And then
to my far left,
we have John Mccutchan.
You've been here at Google
for a grand total of
two and a half days?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: 40 hours?
That's the perfect time to
put him on the internet.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, and we
said that's great, and you're
going to go on TV.
So, John, what are you going
to be doing here?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I'm going to
be working on Native Client
and Dart, bringing better
games to the web.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
COLT MCANLIS: I think
that's good.
TODD KERPELMAN: It so happens
we like the web.
WOLFF DOBSON: We're big fans.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: I don't know if
it's going to last though.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah,
it's a fad.
WOLFF DOBSON: I mean, there's
a story here where I saw one
of the first web browsers
on my NeXT in like 1992.
And I was like, this is
completely disorganized.
How will you be able-- you're
not going to be
able to find anything.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Who's going to
organize our information?
WOLFF DOBSON: No, I didn't think
somebody should organize
this, I thought this is
completely disorganized, it'll
never catch on.
I deleted the browser.
It was really bad.
TODD KERPELMAN: There was a time
when Gopher was just way
more convenient.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, that
was the thing.
It was like Gopher, you knew
where things were.
TODD KERPELMAN: Things were
nicely organized.
COLT MCANLIS: And much like the
Michael Jordan story, the
owners of Google knew that you
said this is impossible.
And that gave them the ambition
to win the gold medal
and launch a company.
Sorry, I'm a big Olympics fan,
so everything this week is
very Olympics-oriented.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
WOLFF DOBSON: I actually did see
Sergey and Larry when they
came out to where I was
in grad school.
They gave a talk about this
company they were thinking
about founding.
COLT MCANLIS: Thinking
about founding?
WOLFF DOBSON: Well,
they were gonna.
They were just kind going on
this little academic tour.
TODD KERPELMAN: Interesting.
WOLFF DOBSON: And I remember
scratching my chin thinking
wow, is that going to work?
I don't even know.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's
so disorganized.
WOLFF DOBSON: There's not enough
understanding in that.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: At
Microtransactions, yes.
COLT MCANLIS: We should actually
talk about something.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, we should
COLT MCANLIS: All right,
moderator, yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: We should
talk about games.
TODD KERPELMAN: So what's
new in NACo Land?
Actually, why don't you start,
for people who don't know what
Native Client is, give
us the pitch.
COLT MCANLIS: Absolutely.
So, Native Client is a
technology that allows you to
run C and C++ code in your
web browser, as safely as
JavaScript, no plug-in
required.
Which is fantastic, because this
means that there's this
perfect little critical point
between developers who pride
themselves on reaching the
maximum amount of users
running on lots of platforms but
still want the executional
control and the speed required
to be able to
actually execute the code.
So the critical thing is that
you can actually run Native
Client code.
So this is C++ code, you've
got an existing code base,
you've got years of development,
engineers have
been trained, millions of
dollars in the code base.
You can run it right in the
web browser without the
plugin, which is typically where
your C++ code on the web
comes in right now.
And of course, most of those
you install the plugin and
than all of sudden you have
like 50 new toolbar
modifications to search for
gophers, and cats, and new
deals on gophercat.com.
So Native Client's a fantastic
technology that we have in
Chrome, and we've been seeing
really good adoption with it.
I think since our official
launch in December of last
year, we've seen over two dozen
games shipped using
Native Client technology
inside of Chrome.
Which is great, right?
I mean, these are games that
span from the indie, to
mobile, to console as well.
We have actually a full suite
of games that have come to
Native Client from consoles
like the Xbox 360.
And they're getting the same
performance, the same
graphics, which is really
inspiring to see.
When you see that kind of
power and that kind of
leverage inside of the web
browser, it's awesome, I love
working on it.
TODD KERPELMAN: So
let's say I'm a
traditional PC game developer.
Why go from having my
EXEs to running
something in a browser?
What do I get out of that?
COLT MCANLIS: Well, first
off is reach, right?
I mean, a lot of developers,
when you're executing in code
in the PC space you have a
certain number of digital
distribution silos that
you're locked into.
Where we are in my opinion in
the digital distribution age
of games right now is really
just a one-off from where we
were a few years ago in
the retail market.
Where effectively, developers
spent a lot of time scrapping
and fighting for market share
and visibility and eyeballs.
We're in a better place because
we're digital, but we
really haven't fixed
that model.
Developers are still spending
tons and tons of time fighting
for small pieces of user
attention in these larger
digital distribution
ecosystems.
The web fixes that.
The web isn't about a single
digital distribution silo,
it's about any link anywhere.
I can send a link to you and you
can go watch a cat skiing
on some little tiny skis made
out of watermelons right now.
And then you can share it with
your friend, and share it with
that friend, and it can go
everywhere and there's no
restrictions on that.
So when you're talking about
gaming on the web, what you're
really talking about is the
ability to touch every human
on the planet.
And put your product,
your artwork, your
game in front of them.
And have them experience that
and have them create an
emotional attachment and then
turn around and be able to
share it with everyone else.
So it's really a powerful
medium.
For those game developers who
understand what the web
brings, it allows them to break
out of a lot of these
molds that there's a lot
of frustration with.
TODD KERPELMAN: Your long-term
goal for game developers is I
can share a game as
easily as I can
share a link to a medium?
COLT MCANLIS: Absolutely.
Can you imagine that?
Like really, imagine this where
you've got an MMO and
you're sitting there playing
inside of your web browser and
you need one of your
buddies to join.
And you pop up your
chat console and
you send him a chat.
And that goes right to him, he
can click on the link, it goes
right into the game, loads the
game, into his character, and
he's right in the instance
with you.
And that's no install, no load
time, hypothetically.
We'd like to optimize
for that.
WOLFF DOBSON: In a world where
assets are incredibly
infinitesimal.
COLT MCANLIS: Or asset transfer
has been optimized in
the correct way.
We see a lot of these console
development systems, you get
seven gigabytes, that takes
time to transfer.
But we have to get into--
and this is, again, another
harp I can get on about
digital distribution silos, but
I'll keep that for later.
Separate discussion.
In any case, that's
the main thing.
If you can actually share a game
and experience a game as
easy as sharing a link, that's
the power of the internet.
That's really what
we're here to do.
And that's really what game
developers have been queueing
on and releasing the power
of Native Client with.
TODD KERPELMAN: Pretty
cool, yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: Or at least
that's my pitch.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's
a good pitch.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I think
it is possible to
really reduce load times.
If you design a game around
the idea that--
let's say an MMO.
If you compartmentalize and
chunk the world up, you should
be able to stream the immediate
world where the
player is landing very,
very quickly.
And then slowly propagate and
fill out the rest of the world
in the background.
COLT MCANLIS: And we've seen
success with this, right?
I mean, Blizzard created Try
WoW which was effectively a
downloadable, free, streamable
client for their World of
Warcraft MMO.
Effectively, if I recall
correctly,
it was like 25 megs.
You would download it, you
could actually play up to
level 20 for free
with this thing.
And what you'd do is you would
download it, and all it
basically gave you was your
character creation screen,
knowing that a user's
going to sit there
and tweak with stuff.
And while they're playing, it
would be streaming in data in
the background.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Exactly.
WOLFF DOBSON: I mean really, if
you think about it, this is
the problem that we've been
going at for 15 years.
And the PlayStation 2 was all
about well, we have all these
different streaming paths
that are going through.
And we have to make sure that
we're actually streaming the
textures in live as we're
rendering it.
And you always had to build in
the lag from oh, we've got to
get it off disk, then we get
it into memory, from memory
onto the graphics runner.
We've been doing this
for 20 years now.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah, it's
definitely an old problem and,
in fact, solved very well.
I don't know if you guys
remember playing Jak and
Daxter back on the PS2, this
had probably one of the
greatest solutions I've
ever seen for this.
So it was a live streaming
world, probably one of the
most successful and one of the
first to really do it.
I don't know if you guys ever
noticed, but if you like just
took off in one direction as
fast as you could go, and the
data wasn't streamed in yet, the
designers actually put in
something funny.
They'd trip your character.
Your character would fall over
and play like a 30-second get
up animation allowing
enough time for
the data to be streamed.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's great.
COLT MCANLIS: That's
brilliant.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's like
those doors in Mass
Effect, or the elevators.
TODD KERPELMAN: The elevators.
WOLFF DOBSON: Ah,
the elevators.
Man, this elevator's
taking forever.
Why did we ever install this?
COLT MCANLIS: Why is floor
two nine million
feet above floor one?
WOLFF DOBSON: Why didn't
we install a pole
just to slide down?
I don't understand.
No, but it is an old problem.
And it's a problem--
well, and I can go all the way
back to-- when I was working
on basketball for the Dreamcast
where you would put
the ball up.
And we didn't have the physics
running all the way forward to
know whether or not the ball
is going to go in.
So we had to stream four or five
different audio clips.
It was like it's in, it's
off the rim, no
good, all these things.
And then by the time the ball
was coming down the arch, we
knew we had five of them
in memory, and then
it wouldn't go in.
And then we'd go ah, it
was this one, and
then we'd play that.
And every now and then we were
spectacularly wrong.
So we'd jump up and swat it
away, and then the commentary
just wouldn't say anything
because we had nothing ready.
COLT MCANLIS: So let
me ask you this.
Do you feel that in the modern
age of development we have
right now that users still
benefit from streaming of
assets and being closer to
instant load as possible?
Do you think that's something
that users actually care
about, that will actually drive
sales for developers?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
Yeah, I do.
TODD KERPELMAN: I
mean, I think it
depends on the system.
Like if I'm going through a
traditional model where I go
on to Steam and I say hey, I'm
going to buy this thing.
Actually, at that point I've
bought it and I've sort of
accepted that maybe, depending
on my internet connection, it
might take a few hours until
I can actually play.
If I could play it right away,
or if I could start playing
and then it asked me for
my credit card or
something like that.
You know, I bet you--
I'm going to say I bet
you could get a few
more sales that way.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Let me give a
scenario, and I think that we
could all relate to this.
You get home from work
and you've got 30
minutes to play a game.
You don't want to spend 10 to
15 minutes of those waiting
for everything to load up, and
get everything started.
You just want to drop in, play
your 30 minutes, and get out.
So streaming absolutely
will help there.
And it's going to make our
very busy schedules
have room for games.
And really high quality games,
too, not just small games.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, I think
streaming and caching together.
Once you have it downloaded,
then you are able to drop back
in instantaneously.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I think if you
organize your game world in
such a way that the immediate
assets you need are five to 10
megs, and then you're streaming
in after that, I
think you could still do
it without caching.
TODD KERPELMAN: I don't know.
I guess that's assuming
everyone's got a very good
internet connection.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: I would love
it if it started streaming
while I was playing.
And then when I was done
playing, it just kept
downloading all the game data.
WOLFF DOBSON: Just kept
chewing on it.
Well, I think Steam
does that, right?
You can start playing Episode
2 when it's half downloaded,
and then it'll keep--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: They have
some checkpoints where
you can start it.
COLT MCANLIS: Well, I think Todd
actually brought up the
crux of the situation here.
We're definitely at an
inflection point.
I think if you're a game
developer right now and you
haven't read the millions of
articles that are talking
about the monetization
differences in the mobile
space, then you're living
under a rock.
Right now we're seeing lots of
studies showing freemium is
definitely dominating in terms
of monetization over
premium-style content.
Like there's still the niche for
it, they're still there,
especially in the Steam platform
where AAA hardcore
developers work in that
premium model.
But I think Todd really caught
on to it where you said you
started with if this is a
premium content, I expect to
buy it and take some time.
But if this is a freemium-style
content--
WOLFF DOBSON: I just want
it to be there.
COLT MCANLIS: Right.
And so that's where I think
the crux is right there.
Even with the monetization
methods that we're seeing have
huge success in the industry
right now, the freemium-style
content, we're still sort of
gated by this mental model
that consumers have given
from our silos.
That I'm going to click a button
and then it's going to
take some time to download, and
then I can play it later.
And that's where, again, I think
I come back to wanting
the webification of games.
Wanting the ability to send
someone a link and have them
instant load it without having
all this install and
everything.
That's really a dream of mine.
That's something that John and I
hopefully will work on a lot
more in the coming years.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, I mean,
I also just like applying
patches, too.
COLT MCANLIS: Oh, yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: Anybody who's
ever left their favorite
console or whatever, or their
game, alone for a while,
they're like yeah, I haven't
played this in forever-- aw.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And there
goes your 30 minutes.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
So definitely all that stuff.
I do find it interesting though,
especially for mobile
gaming, I kind of do want it
all on the device before I
walk out the door.
Because I don't actually
know what my
connectivity is going to be.
COLT MCANLIS: That's
fair, yeah.
Absolutely.
WOLFF DOBSON: Especially for--
I'm going to Alaska
pretty soon.
So no idea what my internet
connection is going to be.
TODD KERPELMAN: I don't know
what your coverage
is going to be there.
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm going to be
adjusting the moose antler.
Yeah, OK.
COLT MCANLIS: Moose internet
connection.
Where do you plug-in?
Just get a moose.
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm very,
very sorry to all
of our Alaska watchers.
TODD KERPELMAN: If they're
watching then
they have good internet.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, I actually
am going out to the national
parks and stuff where the
coverage is going to be poor.
And I'm bringing my
Nexus 7 with me.
COLT MCANLIS: Well, I think
that's just the next place we
should put out Google Fiber is
the Alaskan wildlife park.
WOLFF DOBSON: Is Denali.
Three fourths of the way up
Denali there's like a bunch of
code books.
COLT MCANLIS: I think
it works.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: We'll send
Pitbull up there.
There you go.
WOLFF DOBSON: Because
he's already in
Kodiak, it would be awesome.
COLT MCANLIS: It's all right,
we're completely off-base.
TODD KERPELMAN: No, that's
not, that's fine.
WOLFF DOBSON: So next
question, Todd.
TODD KERPELMAN: Well, I was
actually going to touch on the
freemium model.
Do you feel like that's the
future for all games?
COLT MCANLIS: Oh, absolutely
not, no, no, no.
The way I correlate freemium
versus premium is much like
television versus movies
right now.
Like there is always a market
that someone wants that rich,
immersive, interactive
environment, and that is never
going to go away.
I think the fact that Steam
sales and consoles actually
stayed relatively strong
considering how much attention
and money is now in the mobile
market is proof that there is
definitely a market there and
that's not going to go away.
That's your movie, that's
you're AAA content.
That's your sit down, play
some time, spend a good
weekend ignoring the kids,
shooting some people in the
face, right?
That's there.
TODD KERPELMAN: Good
wholesome fun.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah, good
wholesome family fun.
WOLFF DOBSON: I do that even
without a console.
COLT MCANLIS: What I think we're
seeing right now is that
we've never had an opportunity
for anything but that--
that's been the only medium.
It's effectively like only ever
having bookstores for the
first 20 centuries of human
existence, and then one day
someone starts handing
out leaflets.
And it's like oh wait, I can
actually get some data in a
very short condensed form, and
then go on back with my day.
And because we're a very
attention interrupted society
right now, these devices
we have in our
pocket are very much--
I'm standing in line at the
DMV, I'm waiting to get
punched in the face.
Let me whip out and play some
games and then go back.
It's very much small
installments of
little pieces of data.
I think that's just a different
ecosystem and a
different model, a different
environment.
And they both have their place,
especially when you
look at social games in
social networks and
who that caters to.
I thought Zynga's presentation
a couple years ago at GDC was
completely eye-opening when
their lead designer had talked
about her mental model
of designing games.
WOLFF DOBSON: I remember that.
COLT MCANLIS: Understanding that
when a house mother sits
down to play a game, she's
just had a kid
yelling at her for hours.
She doesn't want to sit down and
try 15 times to shoot an
alien in the face.
She want something that's
progressive and moving
forward, and something that
makes her feel like she's
getting investment
for her time.
That was really eye opening.
That was a medium that, as game
developers, we'd never
considered before.
And I think we just have
more avenues to
explore these voices.
Now, I don't think anything
is going to be the
one dominant future.
Just like anything it'll
ebb and flow.
I think there's going to be
points for all of them.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: An analogy that
I've really liked is like
people are always going to
want to go to a five-star
restaurant, and they're going to
want to go to a sports bar
type restaurant, and they're
going to want to go to
McDonald's.
These are the different tiers.
And just because McDonald's is
out there and cheap doesn't
mean that everyone wants to eat
every meal at McDonald's.
You want different experiences,
and you're going
to get it with different
content.
COLT MCANLIS: Also, by the way,
don't take a McDonald's
hamburger into the
steak house.
Really bad.
Like, they frown on
that entirely.
WOLFF DOBSON: Wait, I've
lost this metaphor.
Does this mean I shouldn't
bring my freemium game--
TODD KERPELMAN: Don't
bring your phone.
WOLFF DOBSON: I can't bring
my cell phone into
Mass Effect, got it.
COLT MCANLIS: That's actually
a great question.
So what was the latest one?
I think it was Mass Effect.
TODD KERPELMAN: It was Mass
Effect where there was a
mobile game that I believe as
you played it, it gave you
bonuses in the actual
retail game.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah, so did you
guys get a chance to try that?
What were your thoughts
on that?
WOLFF DOBSON: It's been
interesting for me with all of
that stuff from the DLC and
the rest of the things for
Mass Effect.
Because Mass Effect is such a
coherent story from one end to
the other when I'm exploring
these side stories.
COLT MCANLIS: Except
the ending.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wait.
COLT MCANLIS: Separate
discussion, sorry.
TODD KERPELMAN: I haven't played
it yet, don't talk
about the ending.
COLT MCANLIS: Sorry.
TODD KERPELMAN: It's
still on my list.
WOLFF DOBSON: We all have
opinions about how it ended.
But as a whole, there's this
coherent thing that happens
running together and
when you go off and
explore these side stories.
Sometimes it deepens your
understanding of what happens.
They had the DLC where you go
and explore your own crashed
ship from the previous game.
Yeah, that's really cool, I'm
seeing the results of this
other thing that was very
important to me in the
previous thing.
At other times it seems sort
of like well, this would be
things that you might cut from
when you were editing this in
the first place.
But they say oh, we had more
stuff so we added on to it.
And I think it's a little bit
like the problem you have when
there are comic books based on
really popular TV shows.
And you think to yourself, I
want to read more about your
favorite TV show, Buffy
or whatever it is.
Except that they can't really
change anything in the
universe in the comic world
because not everybody is going
to be buying the DLC, which
is the comic part.
So it ends up feeling kind of
starved because you say well,
you know, something will
happen, it might be
interesting.
But it's not going to be that
interesting as compared to
what's going to happen
on the thing.
And Buffy interestingly broke
out of that by ending the TV
series and letting the comic
books begin changing the
continuity as they
went forward.
And suddenly the comic books
got 100 times better.
COLT MCANLIS: And I'm really
looking forward to the comic
book series of Cougar Town.
Really looking forward
to that.
I think that's going
to be big.
Mark my words.
TODD KERPELMAN: [INAUDIBLE] a
lot, but it's a good show.
COLT MCANLIS: It
is a good show.
TODD KERPELMAN: It's
a fantastic show.
COLT MCANLIS: It's going to
be a great comic book.
TODD KERPELMAN: Terrible
title, but it's, yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: But I think
the DLC kind of thing
is in there, too.
Where if you're exploring things
that aren't important
to the main story but are
important unto themselves, the
DLC works really well.
And if you're a big fan, you're
just like let me get
out my credit card because I
need more of this action.
COLT MCANLIS: And where's
the limit though?
Because DLC is this concept--
again, it's what John said
about tiers, right?
You've got Microtransaction
which has different variations
of durable achievement, versus
here's a plasma weapon that I
gained, versus some
other thing.
WOLFF DOBSON: Like here's extra
bullets for this one.
COLT MCANLIS: Right, and then
you've got the next level up
which is DLC.
Which really has only been born
in the past couple years
with console.
I remember 2007-2008, DLC was
just really coming out.
Before that there were called
Expansion Packs, and then it
became DLC, and now that's
even getting cut down.
So where's the line
with AAA games?
Again, so we've got Borderlands
which I think did
Microtransaction DLC stuff
very well, we've got Mass
Effect in there.
Do we feel that this
has a proper
place in the AAA industry?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Absolutely.
I think to your point, it either
has to be completely
satisfying on its own, or in
some way actually affect the
game world to make it
really entertaining.
But definitely.
I mean, I'm really looking
forward to the Dark Souls
expansion pack coming
out this fall.
That's a AAA game, and I am
ridiculously excited for it.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah,
I know some hardcore
gamers don't like DLC.
They look at it like oh, the
companies are just holding
back content or leeching
off of us.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's on
the disk already.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
I can see their issue, but it's
like I think the thing
about DLC is one, it provides a
very real incentive for the
developers to make sure
their game is good.
If it's just a title that they
sell you, and then all they've
got to do is get over that
hump of providing enough
[INAUDIBLE]
video.
Or a nice package that you say,
OK, I'll buy this, and
then you find out the
game's not any good.
They've still gotten
their $50-$60.
But with DLC now, they have an
incentive for you to play
through the entire game and say
wow, that was great and I
would like more of this.
So I think it helps in that I
think it provides an incentive
for developers to make sure that
you enjoy their games.
I think from an economics model
it allows you to pay as
little or as much as you want
within limits for the game
experience.
And in some ways I could see
a future where even the AAA
titles, the base
value is lower.
Maybe not zero, but getting
down to $40 or $30 even as
they try and provide a wider
range of I'm sort of a casual
gamer, but I'd like to play some
hardcore console games.
They can get in there with a
cheaper version and then as
you're more and more of a
fan, they can provide
more and more to you.
COLT MCANLIS: Aren't we talking
about episodic content
at that point?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I'm
starting to wonder if that's
what you're going towards
is like a very
limited initial release.
Kind of like back with Doom
where you would get the first
10 stages in Shareware.
WOLFF DOBSON: Or TryWoW where
you get 20 levels.
All of this, I think if I recall
correctly, the economic
term for this is differential
pricing.
Which is knowing you are the
person who wants the premium
experience.
You are the person who wants
the smaller experience.
You're the person who we're just
barely going to be able
to convince to buy this
in the first place.
I mean, you need to provide a
wide variety of options so
that you can figure it out.
Whether it's luxury cars
versus economy cars.
They both get you someplace, but
they obviously have these
very different reward path
sorts of things.
And the same thing is true with
collector's editions.
Collector's editions
are $15 more.
And, I mean, you
get cool stuff.
And I totally have collector's
editions, because they
differentially priced
me very correctly.
I said yes, I would like that,
thank you very much.
COLT MCANLIS: The Halo 3 helmet
was probably the best
one, but it wasn't life-sized
enough.
They gave you this little
Halo 3 helmet.
TODD KERPELMAN: You
couldn't wear it?
COLT MCANLIS: No, you
couldn't wear it.
My child could wear it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Could
a cat wear it?
COLT MCANLIS: Could
You know what, I think we
should Google that.
WOLFF DOBSON: Dead Space gave
you the plasma cutter.
COLT MCANLIS: Oh, really?
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes, I have
the little plastic
clip, plasma cutter.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's nice.
WOLFF DOBSON: Actually, it's
like maybe half-sized, which
means actually my daughter is
perfect and she ran around the
house plasma cutting
things for a while.
COLT MCANLIS: Especially cats.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So the house
just burnt down.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, she
just kept slicing
holes in the house.
Eh, you know.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I think it was
someone from Nintendo that
said a few years ago that the
vast majority of gamers never
reach the end of a game.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, that study's
been done lots of times.
Sierra did it as well,
it's like less than
12% of their users.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So maybe most
consumers would like to be
able to buy the first 30%
of a game and play that.
And then once they've reached
that limit, they're like OK,
now I'm completely dedicated
to this, I'm
going to keep going.
And then you DLC.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, at that
point you need the
frictionless purchase
experience.
Where it's like yeah, this is
awesome, let's keep going
right now and don't let me stop
and get out my wallet.
COLT MCANLIS: And then
have to download 7
gigs worth of content.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So you
definitely have to streamload.
WOLFF DOBSON: And speaking of
streaming, I just remembered
the other thing, which is if
you ever play a game like a
Jak and Daxter Naughty
Dog game.
Try running the opposite
direction down the corridor.
Like if you play Uncharted and
you start running the other
way, it starts like god, because
you weren't supposed
to run that direction.
Don't run backwards.
TODD KERPELMAN: They
need to trip you.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: So we actually
have a question on [INAUDIBLE]
that is related to web games.
COLT MCANLIS: Someone's
watching.
TODD KERPELMAN: On
our moderator.
Yeah.
Thank you everyone
for watching.
So let's see here.
The question is, HTML5 games
use JavaScript game engines
and this code can be
viewed by players.
Is there any way that we can
make sure that the game code
is not edited while saving
high scores?
COLT MCANLIS: So I think there's
some assumptions about
this question that I think are
worth addressing before we
actually answer it.
So the direct question is the
code is not edited while
saving high scores.
So some assumptions there is
that the code itself is
editable in a form that
could save it.
Like whether or not the high
score is saved locally versus
pushed to cloud store, things
along those lines.
I assume that if you do have
some high score that you do
have some login mechanisms.
So there is an authentication
token involved with the
process there, too.
Just to lay the groundwork to
make sure that we're all
talking about the same
thing with that one.
I didn't have an answer.
WOLFF DOBSON: There's lots of
ways to get around that.
This problem exists even outside
of HTML5, and Flash
has this problem in spades.
TODD KERPELMAN: Or Compiled C.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, I mean, I've
never opened up an object
file and begun changing
things.
COLT MCANLIS: What's
an object file?
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes, exactly.
But one of things you can do if
you develop online games is
make sure that the actions that
players do, the ones that
matter, actually have a round
trip to the server.
That's the basic thing to do,
which also stops race
conditions.
You need some place that's
transactional, that players
don't have an entire free access
to the entire way.
Another way to go about that is
authentication systems and
token systems.
We deal with that in Hangouts
all the time.
Where it's like how do I know
that I'm actually acting on
behalf of me, and not-- and then
there's a long discussion
of OAuth and if I had that--